a defiant and powerful message
from iran's spiritual and political
leader ayatollah ali khamenei
the country has been under u.s sanctions
since 2018
khamenei calls them a major act of
criminality
and he took aim at former u.s president
donald trump
the maximum pressure of the united
states has failed
the previous idiots hoped to corner iran
so that it would be forced to go to the
negotiating table
and he could impose his will on weak
iran
his departure was with disgrace he
disgraced not only himself but also
the united states
the new administration of joe biden has
not lifted trump's sanctions
and khamenei says iranians now have to
work on the bases
they will not be removed anytime soon
of course we are patient and we are
doing our job if they accept this policy
that we've put forward
well everything will be all right if not
this existing situation will continue
and there is no problem with it
the message from iran has been
consistent the u.s must lift all
sanctions before it returns to its
commitments under the nuclear deal
but its breaches are of growing concern
to western powers
and the u.s is looking at iran's
presidential elections in three months
to see what kind of administration it
will be dealing with ayatullah ali
khamenei wants a high turnout at the
poles in iran to send a strong message
to the outside world
in every election iran wants to show a
picture of people queuing in front of
polling stations because
this is part of the uh establishment's
legitimacy
this is part of the picture of the
revolution that it's still
alive and that's why in the last
elections in 2020 there was a picture
the establishment didn't want the outs
outside war to see
people not turning out to the elections
maybe less than 50 percent for the first
time
iran has struggled over the last few
years its economy
currency and people have been hurt by
sanctions
but in the lead-up to the election
there's a call for optimism
this was a wide-ranging speech that
covered the economy the upcoming
presidential election and the nuclear
deal
what's apparent is ayatollah khamenei
has a deep mistrust of the united states
and wants to see actions before
iran reciprocates the situation is in a
stalemate
but a leader who's been in power for
more than three decades and seen through
several u.s presidents says
iran is in no hurry to compromise assad
beg
al-jazeera tehran